сьогодні дуже крутий день справа громад
фонд Петра Порошенка разом з тисячами
небайдужих українців передають ЗСУ 11
чудових машин натівського зразку Такі от
Шелбі вони називаються Для наступу що я
вам прислали цей як пропозицію в березні
місяці
одна компанія я показала Цю пропозицію
от вона буквально прийшла мені на пошту
від моїх знайомих І я відразу показала і
Петро олексійовичу кажу слухайте можна
буде це цікаво він каже О так це круті
машини Давай спробуємо і ми почали з
ними переписку і далі відключилася
справа громад всі ці прекрасні люди які
сказали що це важлива справа тому що це
машина насправді натівського зразка тобі
треба показати її всередині тому що вона
всередині ну правда не схожа на те до
чого звикли наші військові на жаль тому
що то переважно Радянська якась техніка
А це зовсім інший рівень і е-е це крута
броня - це круте скло просто такое
товщини і головне це таке оснащення яке
мало де є тому що нам на заводі
наприклад виробнику коли я туди їздила
нам все це показували І розказували щоб
Ти розуміла ото Бачиш якщо навіть скло
випаде то там є три камери а всередині є
екран і ти будеш все одно бачити причому
центрі червоні камери які ти будеш
бачити вночі і ти будеш бачити повний
кут в тебе буде огляду це не просто
машина яка допоможе і забезпечити роботу
і виконання завдань нашої армії а саме
бойових завдань тут все зроблено це дуже
важкі двері Але тим не менш тут все
зроблено Я зараз це покажу бо я скажу що
на заводі нам все показували розказували
а значить там всередині є ще от 6 місць
тут два місця і тут от бачиш ось ці
екрани от тут тобто українська армія яка
за стандартами НАТО вже давно працює в
нас абсолютно навіть скарбія тепер
матиме натівські машини да от подивися
оце все от амортизатори тобто центр те
що ти будеш тут відіб'єш собі все А сюди
заходить десант який висаджується тому
що це машина наступу і це дуже важливо
сьогодні допомогти збройним силам
України організувати цей наступ
Контрнаступ для звільнення української
землі і це їхній захист це їхній ще
насправді цьому ця машина називається
msl Shell більше половину суму насправді
вніс Петро Порошенко і це 11 машин
і це те що дозволить повністю оснастити
десантний батальйон який сьогодні
готується до цю норму по звільненню
зокрема Херсонщини взагалі а всі
українці сьогодні Україна перетворилися
на націю воїнів волонтерів і тих хто
підтримує армію і ми хочемо подякувати
кожному українцю який в той чи інший
спосіб передає донати для арміну а
Звичайно особливі слова нашої подяки тим
хто допомагає у справі громад донатити
на конкретні цілі І от зараз 11 отаких
новеньких шелдінг вони відправляються Ну
от сьогодні на фронт Подивіться яка
крутить абсолютно і ще 350 безпілотників
і 250 ще буде вантажівок от саме за ними
полював Петро Порошенко і наша команда і
це дуже круто сьогодні знати що ми
можемо ми хочемось допомогти армії Якщо
хочете допомогти ЗСУ давайте це робити І
тоді можна таку футболку отримати Бачите
я купую машину ЗСУ Ну це я вам скажу
чесно Ця футболка набагато крутіше ніж
будь-які
парте і від Кутюр тому що
маєш право її носити якщо тільки ти
допоміг армії Церква
[оплески]